favorite memory of prison break which we
didn't really get to talk about
because you played you played a real
[ __ ] on that
you know why you got to go there babe
i'm sorry i mean you were you were tough
misunderstood misunderstood i knew
you're going to say that
favorite memory uh
first two scenes of the first season
that i was in because i came
i was not in season one but then
i remember when i got when i got offered
the job i'm like wait a minute it's i
just they just broke out of prison
after
why is it called prison break what are
we going to do and it was like it's an
fbi agent
first first two scenes when i got to
dallas um
just
i remembered the character and thinking
why is this guy popping pills he's the
fbi agent and he's just got a whole
other rhythm going on and i remember the
beginnings of that
and thinking
this
i like this
i like this a lot you like playing the
character i did i i did yeah and it was
very separate from all the guys that
were the prison break guys from the year
before that and i was i was fine with
that i was just walking on my own road
remember when you would fart every time
you could on set yes and everyone loved
it yes yeah remember when you used to
wear sandals and shorts because they
were only shooting you from the waist up
because it was too warm remember when
you had big feet i
talk though
what do you remember
listen anywhere you get your podcasts or
watch on youtube
you